[Music]
hello i'm sami zaydan this is counting
the cost on al jazeera your look at the
world of business and economics this
week
the war in ukraine could severely impact
the global economy and the imf also
warns the consequences could be lasting
so which countries are most at risk and
is the world heading into a new
financial crisis
also this week cut off from the
international financial system russia
has turned to the chinese yuan to
survive sanctions could other
governments shift away from the us
dollar is the greenback dominance in
danger
crypto currency purchases in rubles have
been rising and governments are worried
russia could evade sanctions using
virtual coins
so is unregulated money really a fix for
russia's financial woes
[Music]
the war in ukraine is obviously hurting
the economies of russia and its neighbor
with both countries expected to
experience sharp recessions this year
but the economic consequences of the war
will not only be felt by parties to the
conflict
sweeping sanctions imposed on moscow and
the soaring price of energy supplies or
they could inflict pain on other nations
too
that's all of course while the world
economy is still recovering from that
coronavirus pandemic
the international monetary fund says the
war could have a severe impact on the
global economy it expects to cut its
growth forecasts globally the imf has
also reduced its estimated global growth
rate for 2022 to
4.4 percent in january that's down from
4.9
last year the most serious threat to the
world economy is soaring inflation which
is already at levels that haven't been
seen in decades
that's mainly driven by the sharp rise
in commodities and food prices
europe with its heavy dependence on
russian energy could be particularly hit
the ukraine war is expected to reduce
eurozone economic growth by as much as
two percentage points consumer prices in
the 19 countries that use the eurozone
currency hit record highs for four
months in a row reaching 5.8 per cent in
february
while the us is also at risk it is
expected to outperform european
countries
the conflict is also putting a fresh
strain on that overstretched global
supply chain pushing up the prices of
many metals
both russia and ukraine export large
amounts of steel palladium platinum and
nickel among others some car makers have
idled factories due to a lack of
components
and it is poor and developing nations
that could suffer the most
among the challenges ahead are trade
shocks a reduction in remittances and
financial instability
but food security could be the most
imminent threat
russia and ukraine are both main
exporters of wheat and parts of africa
and the middle east could suffer severe
shortages
well to discuss all of this now i'm
joined from newcastle in the uk by klaus
vistessen klaus is the chief eurozone
economist with pantheon macroeconomics
good to have you with us so many experts
now are comparing the current situation
to the 1970s energy crisis to the
collapse of the lehman brothers do you
see any of those similarities well i
mean if we're very unlucky it could be a
combination of both right uh because you
have the specter of a russian default
that could be like lehman and you
certainly have
um the um the 1970 style supply-side
driven inflation i mean at the moment i
would say we're more sort of towards the
1970s and in the way that you know
you know demanding the economy strong
and then we've had
pretty much since covet hit we've had a
string of supply side shocks in the
economy the one ukraine is now an
additional supply side shock russia is
is one of the biggest if not the biggest
commodity exporter in the world so but
having that i mean klaus you just said
if we're unlucky this could be
both that's huge are we on the verge of
another major global financial crisis
that's not our baseline but certainly we
are now dealing with events where things
can get out of hand very quickly and
where i think no one knows exactly what
the
ramifications will be right um
so a russian sovereign default um
could it could obviously send other
markets in the tailspin we already have
stressed financial markets so we're
certainly now in in in a in a rather
precarious situation obviously policy is
being tightened although again that
could change but at the moment you know
policy support has been withdrawn
because of high inflation so
um we have a downside risk to growth
inflation is very high which constrains
policymakers at least in the near term
so yeah no certainly the risk of
something adverse happening is certainly
rising i would say you mentioned
inflation then the imf is expected to
reduce its forecasts
are we heading towards the perfect
scenario for stagflation
oh we are in stagflation now i think i
mean if you look at forecasts in general
over the last three months and i would
say this is going to continue for the
next three months also with reference to
your comment now on the imf inflation
forecast will be ratcheted up because as
you as we economists start to factor in
and quantify what what the increase in
commodity prices mean for inflation over
the next sort of six months if you will
inflation forecast will have to go up
but growth forecast will have to go down
so again whether we're staring at the
into a global recession we don't think
that so of course that's probably
sort of mild stagflation but in so far
as goes uh the idea that inflation is
going up but growth is slowing and you
know that's what's happening and you
know that is stagflation wow that's huge
what will that mean for less developed
countries for countries which are
already struggling jordan lebanon
tunisia i mean countries which subsidize
the basics of life
like electricity prices and so on how
will they deal with this challenge well
economies like that are in a very tight
spot now because they will be hit very
hard by the kind of inflation we're
seeing now in food prices basic
commodities whereas the developed
economy are a little bit more shielded
towards that a because they're richer
but but also because their consumer
price indices are not as sensitive to
towards these kinds of of price
increases so
i would say that you know we
you know the the consequences of
effectively if you will shutting the
russian economy in this case
out of the global economy um and and you
know the ramifications that have on on
different commodity markets in an
environment where commodities and
inflation already was kind of hudding up
yeah that that could have quite
significant consequences for for some of
the economies you mentioned there who
obviously to a large extent depend on on
on imported goods in in in some food
stuff of course these economies also
produce a lot of their own stuff but
again some of them are still dependent
on imports what about china china's
growth forecasts are going down it's uh
costs at least of energy going up how's
this going to impact xi jinping's
policies
well i think for china it's a sort of a
balanced situation uh politically of
course they will feel that the extent to
which there's now a widening rift
between you know the east and the west
they feel that they might will be able
to to become sort of a center point in
in the eastern in the eastern part of
this and they will try of course to
politically
exploit that situation but economically
yeah i mean chinese growth is already
under pressure they they have a huge
issue in the property sector which is
affecting large parts of their economy
at the moment and so in that
context the fact that global growth now
seems to be seems to be slowing in the
context of an inflationary shock and
and withdrawal of support in general
that's certainly not a favor uh
certainly not a benefit for china but
generally in terms of the sort of
geopolitics i i think maybe you know
china will feel that they have
opportunities here to uh to to make make
a few points you mentioned developing
you mentioned developed countries
a moment ago let's talk about europe
the continent risking recession right
now
yes there it is i mean that again we
don't think the eurozone will fund the
recession but we certainly we've
recently downgraded our forecast for the
second half of the year reflecting high
inflation a hit to real incomes less
monetary policy support uh so certainly
that's a risk i mean i would say that
the upside in the eurozone is that
fiscal support governments are are
after covert in particular where of
course they've helped the economy a lot
i think they'll be quicker to to rush to
support economies here um you know i
think we will see direct subsidies for
especially low-income households in the
context of uh of protecting them from
from higher energy prices i think we'll
see uh big investments front loaded in
defense spending which also you know has
a boost to that also boost gdp growth in
the short term we'll see big investments
in energy uh infrastructure which also
could be front loaded so i think the
private sector certainly now
will probably face lower i mean have to
grow at a slower pace because inflation
simply is going to sap some of that and
momentum but i think governments are
going to try to offset that of course
that's just going to give any more just
going to push even more on inflation so
in some sense you know if there's one
thing i'm certain about is that
inflation will continue to go higher
everything else is sort of a little bit
uncertain at this point what about the
us we can't talk we can't not talk about
the world's largest economy how
resilient
is the us economy to all of this some
say well it would take all prices going
north of 200 a barrel before the us is
pulled into recession what do you think
well that's the good news uh we think
the u.s economy is relatively resilient
to this you know consumers have lots of
stored up savings they're a little bit
further away from from
from the situation in europe in general
so yes they will import obviously
inflation via higher energy prices but
also remember this is a really really
important point the u.s economy is
different now because the u.s economy
has a big
oil producing sector itself via shell
which means that as all prices go up yes
it affects the u.s consumer negatively
but they have a lot of savings but it
also boosts energy cap so this old story
in which you know all prices go up and
that immediately hits u.s growth it's
not necessarily the same anymore we we
think that you know there could be even
be a positive correlation between higher
oil prices and capex investment and
growth in the us because you'll see all
production start to pick up so the us is
resilient that's very good news for the
global economy because obviously that
will become i mean if the us economy
does well you know that already there
means that the global economy is on a
relatively decent footing even if you
know you have weakness elsewhere
all right thanks so much been good
talking to you same same thank you for
talking
sanctions imposed by the west on russia
are reviving an old debate on whether
countries should hold dollar-based
central bank reserves you see the worry
is they may lose access to those
reserves when they need them the most if
they run foul of the west the russian
government has been at risk of
defaulting on its debt not because
moscow doesn't have the money actually
it does but it can't access almost half
its foreign reserves which have been
frozen by western capitals
russia says it's made 117 million
dollars in interest payments it owes to
investors but the money could be blocked
by the us the russian finance ministry
says the nation would try to pay in
rubles if this happens moscow has a
30-day grace period in which the
government should pay up
if it doesn't that would constitute a
default
it would be the first time the country
fails to meet its financial obligations
since the 1917 bolshevik revolution
well russian banks and firms are
increasingly turning to china's currency
the yuan as they face isolation from the
west
lender vtb bank is offering a chinese
currency savings account with a maximum
interest rate of 8 percent others are
also looking to start using china's
union pay system for credit cards after
visa and mastercard suspended operations
in russia the dollar has been the
world's reserve currency since the
bretton woods agreement in 1944
russia held a hundred billion dollars or
sixteen percent of its foreign reserves
in u.s dollars as of june 2021
another 32 percent was held in euros and
the country has been trying to reduce
its holdings of u.s dollar denominated
assets in recent years it sold off all
of its u.s treasuries in 2018.
moscow also held over 120 billion
dollars worth of gold more than its
actual dollar denominated holdings the
commodity is effectively its primary
holding given the loss of access to
dollars and euros
the yuan is the world's fifth largest
reserve currency central banks held at
least 319 billion us dollars worth of
yuan reserves in the third quarter of
2021 some economists say there's an
effort underway to build an alternative
financial system to that dominated by
the us they say the yuan together with
gold and crypto currencies are likely to
gain market share at the expense of
western currencies well to discuss this
i'm joined now by timothy ash he's a
senior emerging market sovereign
strategist at blue bay asset management
joins us now from london good to have
you with us so has the one become
russia's new dollar or is it becoming
russia's new dollar i don't buy it um i
think what's interesting uh about this
crisis
is the unwillingness of of the chinese
uh to bankroll russia and to kind of
help the russians circumvent sanctions
and we've seen that kind of across the
board i mean
you know lots of criticism sanctions uh
from the west and their ineffectiveness
but actually the financial sanctions
that have been lobbied so far
and the fact that energy has not really
been sanctioned it's quite incredible
that companies just do not want to
transact with russia including for
energy because of financial sanctions so
bottom line is the dollar is still king
all right but regardless of how willing
the chinese are or are not
is distrust global destruct distrust
growing in the u.s dollar because russia
is not the first country that's you know
been deprived access to its assets we
have we've had iran north korea the
taliban and so on
i don't think so i mean uh
you know what's again notable is offac
the u.s treasury in the western
sanctions machine is just so uh so
powerful
that what this shows is you may you may
find alternative ways to transact but in
the end western sanctions will find you
and all these companies the chinese
banks etc they're desperate
to avoid being caught in secondary
sanctions so even if there are these
alternative payment mechanisms you know
ofac will find you eventually and you
will be hit by these secondary sanctions
so it doesn't really solve the
underlying problem that you you have an
entity like russia is sanctioned because
of its bad behavior ofac is going after
you and companies simply do not want to
be caught
in the firing line of ofac maybe we
should focus a little bit now on the
sanctions and just how unprecedented are
the sanctions not in russia but
particularly on its reserves its foreign
currency reserves well pretty remarkable
i mean uh you know no one expected the
cbr to be sanctioned a central bank it's
kind of unheard of uh you know and it
came so quickly i mean i remember the
week uh you know that week there was a
research paper i think on the wednesday
or thursday highlighting that this was
an option uh there was intense negotia
or intense discussions i know on the
saturday uh in washington around it and
then it was done on the sunday i mean
utterly utterly remarkable but
devastating for russia you know russia
thought it was in this uh this
untouchable position with 640 billion of
fx reserves it could withstand anything
the west through it and then ofac you
know dropped the bombshell uh
sanctioning uh the the cbr reserves and
it put a huge weight of those reserves
beyond their reach they've got gold i
guess in in their vaults they've got
physical cash uh there is obviously some
some swap lines with the chinese but
even the chinese i think are reluctant
really to help them out very much again
this idea you know they don't want to be
caught in secondary sanctions uh for
helping out russia so you know it's put
russia in an incredibly difficult place
on the bridge brink of default their
financial markets of of all have totally
collapsed it's extraordinary you know 95
loss in in value across the board
equities bonds and the currencies come
under massive pressure so russians
because of these sanctions are
a lot poorer today than they were a
month and a half ago because of putin's
actions and notable i think there is
they did not expect it you know the
foreigners generally reduced exposure to
russia the biggest holders of russian
assets are russians themselves they
believe the rhetoric let me know let me
jump in there
despite that despite the unprecedented
nature of targeting a central bank as
you just explained for us you don't
think you don't agree with those
analysts who say this could be a turning
point this could be the birth of a new
monetary order
i don't think so you know i mean uh what
are russians
dashing for what do the guy what does
the guy in the street in moscow want to
get his hands on he doesn't want to get
his hands on wan
or you know he wants to get his hands on
dollars you know these are maybe
cryptocurrency convertible currencies
use of cryptocurrencies shot up on
february 24th well maybe but you know
it's hard still to
transact uh
in anything you know significant with
crypto and i think of is coming after
crypto in the end if crypto is going to
be used to break sanctions
crypto will feel the weight of western
financial sanctions as well all right
what about gold you mentioned gold there
what's the possibility that the russian
ruble becomes well even at least de
facto backed by gold now
well you know it doesn't really
it doesn't resolve the underlying
problem uh that
even if you can transact even if it's
legal to transact with russia and trade
with russia
people do not want to people do not want
to take the ethical risk of transacting
with uh with putin's russia because of
what he's done in ukraine well it's been
good talking to you thanks so much
timothy my pleasure cheers
another asset seen as an alternative
medium of international exchange to the
dollar is cryptocurrency many
governments are worried the digital coin
could provide a hidden route for
sanctioned russians to preserve their
wealth
the virtual money is unregulated and it
bypasses the international banking
system which of course is key to
enforcing those sanctions
and the exchanges have come under
pressure to address violation concerns
they've resisted several calls to block
russian users as a whole and are not yet
legally obliged to do so however major
cryptocurrency exchanges like finance
say they will comply with sanctions and
abide by the law
but there are thousands of smaller less
strict exchanges which could step in and
allow the transactions
the cryptocurrency research firm kaiko
says the average trade size of bitcoin
ruble transaction hit a 10 month high on
february 24th when russia invaded
ukraine
it's estimated more than 17 million
russians or 12 percent of the population
invest in cryptocurrency
russia ranked 18th worldwide in terms of
cryptocurrency adoption it had the third
largest share of overseas transfers
after turkey and ukraine
russian entities that are under
sanctions have been accused of using
ransomware attacks for revenues the
blockchain tracking firm chanalysis says
around 74 percent of that income or 400
million dollars went to entities that
could be affiliated with russia last
year
well joining me now is kaya parv the
chief investment officer at
creditlink.ai an artificial
intelligence-enabled credit asset
management company she joins me from
singapore good to have you with us so
kaya can cryptocurrencies provide an
alternative to the us dollar do you
think
at this point decentralized
cryptocurrencies definitely do not
provide an alternative for u.s dollar
u.s dollar is still backed by the
world's most largest and powerful
economy as well as the trade and
financial flows crypto does not provide
such backing at this point
having said that digitalized currencies
and perhaps fiat back crypto could
replace usd to some extent and we have
seen some tests already rolled out in
china whereby the pbosc has issued
digitalized iran that has been injected
into digital wallets the use case for
such money could make sense in the event
of natural disaster or even with the
current ukrainian crisis
can it go any distance in helping
countries like russia to evade sanctions
i think it's difficult to use crypto to
even sanctions because if you look at
the size of russian
is currently about 1.7 trillion whereas
the entire market capitalization of
crypto is 1.8 trillion so crypto does
not have the capacity or the death to
allow russia to evade sanctions
and maybe maybe not all the sanctions
can it be helpful i mean obviously as
you pointed out the volume there simply
doesn't cover all of russia's needs but
can it go some length to some extent i
would say yes and if we look at russia's
decision to allow crypto transactions
earlier this year although there was a
lot of debate around banning crypto we
could insinuate that perhaps the
decision was um influenced by the
ukrainian invasion and we can't rule out
maybe there was some sort of tip-off to
oligarch closer to putin that you may
want to move some of your assets to
crypto markets
what can governments do to monitor
activities with cryptocurrency they
consider to be illegal
it's a bit tricky to monitor i mean of
course governments can do what they
always do which is impose more
regulation be it in the form of
transaction reporting or transaction or
taxation or even straight out banning
but um generally the market places where
crypto is traded are already regulated
one way or the other meaning that those
marketplaces operate in heavily
regulated jurisdictions such as the us
or the eu and the endpoints are
regulated meaning if you want to do
crypto transactions you have to use a
major currency such as the euro or the
usd um against it
all right we saw a huge uptick in crypto
transactions on february the 24th
from russia
what are people using it for if as you
said there is it's kind of limited in in
terms of how far it can go to help
with sanctions evasion i think we could
be seeing the first real use case for
crypto with this ukrainian crisis as a
lot of
individuals as well as entities are
moving some of their
money and some of their assets into
crypto so crypto could be proved to be a
store of wealth at this point in time
although we can't really do any actual
transactions in crypto yet
so this could trigger
individuals just average savers
increasingly looking towards
cryptocurrency not just sanctioned
oligarchs
i would say so and um looking at the
comments coming from let's say coinbase
and some of the other markets
they have said pretty pretty
straightforwardly they are not going to
ban russian individuals doing
transactions on their markets because
they feel they can't penalize
individuals and i would agree with that
um but having said that limited access
to the end points um let's say the
dollar and the euro definitely puts a
bit of halt on uh entering crypto for
regular russians
all right it's been great talking to you
thanks so much kaya thank you so
much that's our show for this week but
remember you can get in touch with us
via twitter use the hashtag ajctc when
you do or drop us an email
countingthecost at al jazeera.net is our
address
there's more for you online at
aljazeera.com ctc that'll take you
straight to our page which has
individual reports links and entire
episodes for you to catch up on
that's it for this edition of counting
the cost i'm sami zaydan from the whole
team here thanks for joining us the news
and al jazeera is next